hey guys owns a gun so I did a little
bit of a traveling of this past week and
in my travels I was doing a lot of
driving not a very good driver but
that's a whole nother story something
that I did notice is while I'm driving
I'm quite perceptive of things around me
which is a good thing to do when you're
driving I don't think people are aware
that when you're driving you can see
them I can see you inside of your car
you can see me inside of my car if
you're a freaking like digging around or
I would have no like changing your
clothes I've actually changed tire full
outfit out of red light before and
didn't even think twice about it just
like rip my shirt off throw another
shirt on oh hey put my car in park
change my pants switch my shoes this
isn't that I definitely don't think that
you should ever do because I mean i was
obviously at red light you know stop
that was safe sort of safe sorry mom
sorry police for sure it's illegal there
were no questions on my driver's test
that said hey lou engle to change your
clothes in the red light i don't know i
probably would have missed it anyway I
cheated on my driver's test no I did it
oh my god I'm losing a mind this was
more of a PSA and let you know that um
hey if you're driving a new car guess
what other people can see what you're
doing in there the thing that gets me is
I just will look up and I will see
people just legit full fist in the nose
dig in and grinding up in there gettin
whatever is up there out I see people
just making that nice little laughter
right turn left right left right left no
no no see me digging that's one thing
that drives me nuts when people are
driving there are so many other things
that drive me crazy about driving I am
NOT a very good driver let me know if
you guys have any sort of similar
experiences so let me know how many of
you guys actually can't drive yet
because I'm kind of curious to know it's
all you got for you guys today make sure
you guys like this video if you liked it
don't forget to subscribe you'll see
what I post more videos and I will see
you guys in my next video they see me
dig in
no like I need another song I'm just
trying to get something out of them